bonjour nous sortons de nos locaux de
téléphiles soixante dix huit pour vous
proposer un nouveau rendez vous
politique tous les quinze jours ici le
temps dans un café nous allons échanger
avec un maire un élu de proximité il
sera question de son parcours de sa
commune mais aussi de son regard sur
l'actualité première invitée de ce café
politique c'est michel laugier le maire
de montigny-le-bretonneux bienvenu merci
d'être le premier à participer à ce
nouveau rendez vous et lui en mars
dernier une nouvelle fois et lui aussi
pour la première fois cette fois ci à
président de la communauté
d'agglomération de saint-quentin premier
président de droite vous êtes un homme
de droite un homme du centre aussi
puisque vous avez fait campagne par le
passé avec le soutien de l'udf du modem
de l'ump
vous êtes tous le plus à l'aise
aujourd'hui je suis à l'aise quand je
subis chaîne logique tout simplement ils
ne voulaient pas d'étiquette politique
j'ai des idées j'aime et que j'ai mes
convictions je suis un homme plutôt à
droite dès aujourd'hui
je n'ai pas besoin d'avoir une structure
partisane autour de moi se qui m'aime me
suive et je pense que on peut aussi
progressé faire des choses sans
forcément avoir une carte de son parti
politique mais ça permet de se dégager
aussi de certaines contraintes des
parties d'être un peu plus libre aussi
lorsqu'on voit les difficultés
rencontrées par exemple à l'ump vous
vous dites je suis bien content de pas y
être en ce moment au moins ça m'évite
d'avoir pourquoi pas répondre à des
questions sur sa savez s'il y avait que
l'ump ce serait facile mais regardez
dans tout autre parti c'est exactement
aussi la même chose donc j'étais
militant j'ai été même délégué
départemental de l'idf pendant plusieurs
années et aujourd'hui je n'ai plus
retrouvé une famille dans laquelle je ne
sente parfaitement bien mais à l'aise
sauf que aujourd'hui la véritable
politique que l'on mène c'est celle que
mène sur le terrain et celle qui est
reconnu par les par les habitants après
le reste c'est de la politique
politicienne
justement l'engagement politique ça
remonte à quand pour vous êtes diplômé
de l'école supérieure de journalisme
vous avez été ensuite aux nouvelles de
versailles au début des années 80 un
responsable de l'information régionale
aussi sur le radio cvs canal versailles
stéréo c'était une des premières radios
libres des années 80 deux à quel moment
vous avez eu cette fibre et ou politique
vous vous êtes dit le journalisme ça ne
suffit pas de relater ce que font les
politiques moi aussi je veux être acteur
hausse a été beaucoup plus long que ça
c'était beaucoup plus long que ça
puisque dans un premier temps je suis
venu travailler aux côtés de nicolas
douchez créé son cabinet tout le service
communication dont travaillons
au quotidien avec des élus petite hattie
bien ça nous laisse la possibilité de
réfléchir de gannat lisez ce qui peut se
faire et c'est comme ça que vous à vous
arriver petit à petit dans le monde
politique
vous savez aujourd'hui moi je suis maire
de montigny président de la communauté
d'agglomération de saint quentin
je peux vous dire j'avais jamais pensé
même en me rasant mais les choses sont
venues tout naturellement donc moi je
prends la vie comme aigle et comme elle
vient surtout et j'essaie d'être
toujours à la hauteur des challenges qui
me sont bien représentés dans ces parts
uniquement un concours de circonstances
forcément moment il ya eu cette envie il
n'y a pas une frustration lorsque vous
étiez journaliste
absolument pas je n'ai jamais tué fruits
puisqu'au départ même j'étais jury ce
sportif voyait ce n'était pas du tout le
monde entre dans la politique on est
très loin de la politique sauf qu'après
bien effectivement j'ai interviewé
beaucoup de leaders politiques
d'ailleurs c'est sympa parce que ceux
qui commençaient à éclore dans le
département des yvelines aujourd'hui ce
sont ceux qui sont en place et que je
connais depuis très très longtemps
donc c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas eu le même
parcours mais finalement on est arrivé
presque le niveau
vous pourriez auriez pu faire carrière
du côté d'aix en provence parce que vous
êtes originaire d'aix-en-provence ses
jeux sur une aire de provence mais vous
avez là c'est pareil ce sont les
circonstances
quand vous sortez de l'école du
journalisme surtout dans au début des
années 80 plutôt fin des années soixante
dix
y'avait pas encore les radios libres il
n'y avait pas encore tout ça il va pas
cet engouement pour tous les médias et
donc j'ai vite compris qu'en provence
j'aurais du mal à faire mon trou et donc
c'est comme ça que je me suis retrouvé
en région parisienne où vous devenez
maire vous devenez ensuite sa trace à
mon président de la communauté d'agglo
laisser passer des choses beaucoup de
choses mais sans y consacrer plus qu'une
émission aussi fonder une famille j'ai
des enfants
même aujourd'hui une petite fille donc
j'ai eu un parcours finalement auquel je
m'attendais absolument pas puisque je
voulais être journaliste de presse
écrite dans le sport je me suis
retrouvée alors je les fais pendant
quelque temps je me suis retrouvé à la
radio ensuite j'ai travaillé dans la
communication d'une collectivité
je suis parti dans le privé aussi
m'occuper de l'affichage extérieur dans
un grand groupe
voilà donc des choses auxquelles j'avais
jamais pensé et puis ben effectivement
l'environnement de la politique c'est
être là où je me suis le plus épanoui et
c'est comme ça donc je suis revenu
travailler a menti et que j'étais
attaché à ce parcours de journaliste il
en reste coi d'ailleurs aujourd'hui du
journaliste il aura ce quelque chose là
il reste que je suis à l'aise quand je
suis face à vous déjà parce que j'étais
à votre place
on va voir si les gars il ya quelques
années voilà ça c'est là pas la première
chose et la deuxième chose
oui effectivement parce que j'ai
toujours plein d'amis qui sont restés
dans le dans le métier et que j'entends
à la radio que je vois à la télé nicolas
poincaré pascale clark philippe zickgraf
à la ce sont des amis avec qui on a
commencé aujourd'hui ça me fait toujours
plaisir quand je les retrouve de me
sentir un petit peu avec eux on en
revient tout de même à la politique
avant de passer ensuite à la seconde
partie de cette émission parlera plus
des dossiers spécifiques de votre ville
à la politique parce que donc vous êtes
élu président de la communauté
d'agglomération en mars dernier pour la
première fois au mois d'avril après
l'élection municipale de mars et avril
sont municipales de mars
en tout cas vous arrivez aux affaires et
pour la première fois on retrouve un
homme politique de droite du centre
droit à saint quentin en yvelines est ce
qu'à ce moment là vous vous dites ça y
est enfin on va récupérer ce qu'on a pas
eu par le passé
est ce qu'il ya un petit sentiment aussi
de revanche à ce moment-là vis-à-vis de
la gauche qui a toujours détenu
l'agglomération de saint quentin
tout à fait mais je pense que pour nous
c'est toujours été un challenge andrada
rêver pendant pendant très longtemps toi
surprenant politique c'est pour essayer
de faire triompher ses idées sa façon de
voir les choses
sauf que c'est pas vous qui avez toute
la maîtrise ce sont les électeurs qui on
décide
les électeurs pendant de nombreuses
années en ont décidé autrement
et bien c'est vrai que on a toujours
mené notre combat et au mois de mars
dernier
le résultat nous a donné la possibilité
de pouvoir gérer cette ville
vous savez on a bien examiné on a bien
regardé depuis longtemps plus cette
ville on la connaît bien sûr celles qui
sont il n'y a pas de revanche de
sentiment de devenir voilà il ya des
choses qu'on n'a pas eue là on va les
avoir et il ya une tête même que cette
fois ci les dossiers pour les autres
communes à gauche on va pas les accords
d je ne pense pas que je me rase
absolument pas ou alors ou alors je dire
moi c'est que vous vous connaissez mal
je crois pas avoir cette image là je
suis pas en situation de revanche
par contre je suis en situation de
prouver qu'en gérant autrement on peut
aller encore plus loin c'est tout c'est
une sédation la seule différence il n'y
a pas de revanche avoir par rapport à ce
qui s'est passé puisque je suis qu elle
même
j'ai beaucoup de respect pour la
démocratie dont jusqu'à présent la
population n'avait pas donné la
possibilité d'être aux commandes
aujourd'hui nous l'avons et bien je sens
un esprit de revanche mais par contre
avec beaucoup d'ambition prouver que ce
que nous souhaitons faire était mieux
qu'eux et et mieux sera mieux que ce qui
se faisait avant
donc on va passer la seconde partie de
cette émission va parler de ces dossiers
justement qui concerne votre commune et
saint-quentin-en-yvelines forcément
puisque scellier
oh
seconde partie de ce café politique
toujours avec michel logis on va donner
la parole aux habitants de votre commune
que nous sommes allés rencontrer quels
sont les plus quels sont les moins de
cette ville de montigny je vous laisse
prendre la tablette qui est juste en
face de vous pour écouter les
commentaires des habitants de montigny
le bretonneux
ce qui est positif c'est pour les
les jeunes parents avec des enfants
c'est tout ce qui est le cadre de vie
les parcs d'activités genre de choses
après ce qui manque c'est plus un
accueil pas voir personnellement mais un
psychologue et coûte en fait à ma fille
si calme si collet municipal la
convivialité la proximité des des
activités sportives culturelles
il faudrait améliorer c'est un petit peu
l'animation des marchés locaux par
quartier cette ville nouvelle qui a tout
prévu c'est-à-dire activités sportives
activités culturelles à la sorte de
récit nous avions un marché très
conviviale qui a disparu et ça je le
déplore ou qu'on est bien montigny
simplement qui me manque un commerçant à
côté de chez bret la place des prêts
très bien on vit bien ici à plein de
chemins piétons ce très agréable c'est
bien desservi le cadre de vie c'est ce
qui revient le plus souvent
il ya beaucoup de points positifs mais
aussi quelques attentes pour les
animations notamment vous avez quelques
réactions est-ce qu'il ya longtemps très
peu de manière générale d'ailleurs même
voyez bien les îles montagneuses avait
rencontré sont tout à fait heureux
d'être dans cette ville où ils ont de
bien indiquer que tout était fait pour
un cadre de vie agréable pour les
enfants
la dame qui m'a parlé de la supérette
des prêts elle va ouvrir dans quelques
semaines puisque c'est l'ancien franprix
qui
a souhaité venir s'installer maintenant
auprès donc a pas de souci donc dit
s'être déjà rassuré sur les marchés
effectivement c'est un vrai problème
parce qu'on n'est pas une ville
historique dans les marchés forains
par contre d'un qui fonctionne
assez bien sûr sur canal c'est vrai que
celui de la sourderie a besoin d'être
redynamisé sauf qu'aujourd'hui on a du
mal à trouver des forums tout simplement
c'est pas aussi facile que ça à trouver
des commerçants de bouche
aujourd'hui c'est de plus en plus rares
avec toutes les normes qui doivent
appliquer donc ça c'est une profession
qui petit à petit commence à disparaître
et puis le marché y était mais faute
encore que les habitants fassent vivre
un gros marché
c'est pas le tout d'avoir un marché
encore quand faut il y aller exactement
harcèlement d'y aller sur le reste de
goûter je suis plutôt satisfait de voir
que les habitants apprécient la
politique que nous menons depuis toutes
ces années
juste pour rester sur cet aspect
commerce cadre de vie même si ça ne
dépend pas directement de la
municipalité
il ya forcément un dossier qui doit vous
préoccuper c'est skywest ce centre
commercial qui a été inauguré à c'était
le 16 mars 2005 en grande pompe ont
parlé d'un centre commercial d'un
nouveau type qui devait drainer beaucoup
de populations une nouvelle population
même à 50 ans mylène de nouveaux clients
dix ans plus tard c'est un échec il
devait se relancer avec un projet de
déstockage de marques de luxe
ça n'a pas pu aboutir pour une clause de
non concurrence aujourd'hui c'est un peu
une verrue sur cette ville basse et une
résilience cinéma y règne enfin il reste
le cinéma qu'il fait de bien même qu'il
ya des cinémas qui fonctionne mais en
france puisque ce même si la
fréquentation un peu baissé ces derniers
mois peut-être justement parce qu'il ya
moins de commerces et c'est en fonction
du temps c'est en fonction du temps à
les voir le directeur il vous dira qu'il
a eu a été extraordinaire pour lui c'est
bien sûr mais c'est exactement voilà
parce que parce qu'il fait beau
donc c'était aussi un pas que ça c'est
parce qu'ils sont aussi les odeurs en
tous les cas l'activité cinéma marche
toujours bien et ça va pas empêcher ceux
qui venaient aussi des matches on ne
venait pas pour autre chose
simplement aujourd'hui je suis en
négociation enfin en négociation en
contact fréquent avec les propriétaires
ils ont quand même investi beaucoup
d'argent pour
devenir propriétaire de ce site là et
donc ils les projets avant ce petit à
petit sauf que on ne peut pas sortir
avec une seule en scène est obligé de
venir avec la totalité du plan de
relance de skywest mais ça vous inquiète
pas ne te fais pas vécu comme un échec
même si ça ne dépend pas uniquement de
la ville mais lorsque le centre est
arrivé à la ville l'agglomération était
j'étais très heureux chose après c'est
que le losc eux il ya une différence est
une orientation différente de celle
prévue sur tel qu'au départ c'était un
centre tournée vers la culture et le
loisir dès qu'on est venu en concurrence
avec espace saint quentin
tout de suite on a vu que ça n'a plus
fonctionné on va pas venir sur la guerre
et qui a pu y avoir entre différents
groupes
je devais pas parce que ça serait trop
long à expliquer en tout cas je peux
vous dire c'est que aujourd'hui les
propriétaires de skywest souhaite
relancer ce centre de très bonnes façons
on va juste faire une parenthèse
toujours autour de ce centre mais sur la
sécurité parce que forcément ça pose
aussi quelques soucis en centre
commercial déserté
ça amène forcément des bandes des
bagarres y en avait quelques unes lors
de la campagne municipale la sécurité ça
faisait aussi partie des points de
programme sur les différentes
candidatures vous disiez d'ailleurs que
l'état ne n'est plus assez moyen police
nationale que la ville devait se
substituer un petit peu à l'état avec
installation de vidéo surveillance par
exemple aujourd'hui vous en êtes où
quelques mois après c'est cette campagne
a coûté quelques mois à peine j'ai
toujours sur le même politique j'ai pas
attendu d'être group aig municipal en
campagne électorale pour agir pour agir
parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est vrai qu'au
niveau de l'état on n'a plus les moyens
suffisants et au manque de policiers
donc moi je renforce la
vidéosurveillance sur la ville rappelle
connais des communes où il ya le plus de
gaberone à plus de 50 caméras on a une
police municipale forte de trente 30
agents ce qui est aussi une des plus
importantes du département des yvelines
quant aux événements que ça serait bien
aussi de remettre un petit peu vous vos
affiches à jour parce que si à cames
très longtemps qui a pas eu de bagarre
doivent affrontements tels que vous
d'accord mais on ne peut pas toujours
faire bien sûr c'est juste voilà donc
c'est pour ça mais c'est pour ça que
c'est un peu dommage que on casse un
petit peu une image s'est très vite fait
en rappelant ce qui s'est passé il ya
quelques années ça peut-être qui
freinerait il ya quelques jours
non absolument pas ski fans et des
investisseurs aujourd'hui c'est que sur
pareil il suffit qu'il y en a
quelques-uns qui signe pour que les
autres arrivent donc aujourd'hui ce
qu'on a ce qu'on attend c'est vraiment
un groupe leader qui viennent qui
viennent de s'installer pour que les
autres suivent
la sécurité c'est un thème qui était
très fort pendant la campagne est un
thème qui est très fort pour le front
national le front national qui a fait
son entrée au sein de votre conseil
municipal avec un élu vous l'avez vécu
comment l'arrivée du front national au
sein d'un conseil municipal
écoutez ce fait j'ai un élu comme un
autre se fait jamais tellement plaisir
mais pour moi c'est un lieu comme une
autre qui aujourd'hui participe au débat
municipal et et vote en son âme et
conscience viraux moi aujourd'hui
j'avais j'ai pas besoin de la voix du
front national pour faire adopter les
délibérations que je peux me présenter
en conseil municipal
donc à chacun d'eux à chacun de mener à
bien sa barque je dirais c'est pas moi
de dire si le fonds national doit faire
quelque chose ou pas c'est de sa
responsabilité
en tout cas moi je ferai tout de toute
façon pour qu'il y ait de moins en moins
deux adversaires politiques toutes
tendances pris toutes tendances
politiques confondues c'est déjà avec un
camel meriem parce que j'étais quand
même moins aujourd'hui devait me lors du
précédent voilà donc ma déposition de
monde que lors du précédent monde le
représentant principal de l'opposition
socialiste et c'est vivien gasc dans
cette émission les opposants ont aussi
eu la parole il vous interpellent ils
ont quelques questions à vous poser et
je vous laisse écouter cette première
question de vivien gasc bonjour votre
projet phare c'est la réalisation d'un
pôle culturel dédié au théâtre la
musique sur le site de l'ancien collège
de bergson
alors j'ai une question qui consiste à
savoir comment le projet sera inséré
dans l'agglomération et dans la ville
dans l'agglomération parce que jusqu'à
présent montigny c'est un petit peu au
bord de la route en termes d'intégration
dans l'agglomération je pense au plan
culturel notamment avec le la mise en
place du kiosque le système de
réservation de la casse qui donc je vais
savoir quels sont les complémentarités
que vous envisagez entre cet équipement
et les autres équipements communautaires
les autres équipements qui sont présents
sur l'agglomération
et puis dans la ville je veux savoir
quel est le dialogue quelles sont les
modalités de dialogue que vous envisagez
avec les riverains avec les associations
concernées de près ou de loin par le
projet et avec les conseillers
municipaux de la majorité de
l'opposition
votre réponse sur ce pôle bergson drogba
réponse ce berceau de geomar ma réponse
monsieur gasc qui a conduit la liste de
gauche qui a fait le plus mauvais
résultat sur montigny depuis l'histoire
et ça n'enlève rien à la question la
démocratie ni non mais parce qu'il a
toujours un côté provocateur
parce que comme il dit qu'il ne connaît
pas les affaires de la ville il faut
toujours qu'il ait un côté provocateur
sur le paul derksen les choses sont
claires depuis très longtemps et les
habitants ne savent d'ailleurs s'ils ont
renouvelé leur confiance très largement
c'est qu'ils savent que ils peuvent me
faire confiance le pôle personnes sera
bien sûr un pôle important de culture
avec le conservatoire de musique l'école
de théâtre c'est que les écoles de danse
et en y rajoutant aussi le pôle musiques
amplifiées donc c'est un très grand pôle
culturel
aujourd'hui tous les tous les
les acteurs tout les bénéficiaires tout
le monde en est convaincu et comptant
alors une application avec le reste de
l'agglomération ce sera une structure
uniquement c'est une subtile ce disque
sera elle sera financée uniquement par
la ville de montigny est en tout cas ce
n'est plus de la compétence de
l'agglomération aujourd'hui de financer
des équipements communaux donc c'est la
ville qui fera ceci monsieur gaz fait
allusion à la réservation en ligne des
spectacles sur la politique culturelle
je rappellerai que déjà c'est la ville
de montigny qui consacrent le plus gros
budget à la culture de tout et les
communes de saint quentin en yvelines
ça c'est la première chose deuxièmement
pourquoi aujourd'hui je me participer au
kiosque que de manière très limitée tout
simplement parce que nous avons une
programmation culturelle qui affiche
complet à tous les spectacles donc je
n'ai pas besoin de me mettre en place
que je n'ai pas de place à proposer par
contre ce que je propose c'est que à
l'issue du forum des associations s'il
reste quelques places dont des
spectacles
ceux ci sont bien sûr mis en communauté
avec les autres mais pour le moment je
n'ai pas besoin d'autres structures
puisque les spectacles de proposons
suffisent à eux mêmes pour faire le
plein mais sur le pôle culturel il y
aura une implication des élus
d'opposition aussi sur le projet c'était
la deuxième partie de sa question
ils auront à voter lorsque je leur
présenterai des délibérations et le
projet il peut y participeront bien sûr
à l'élaboration des choses furent
n'osions puisque on va pas commencer les
travaux comme ça il va falloir aussi qui
est différentes délibérations donc ils
auront le droit aussi de pouvoir
s'exprimer sans aucun problème autre
question elle porte sur le vélodrome
cette fois-ci autres quartiers
importants pour la cette loge noms
doivent être réalisés dans le futur
nouveau quartier autour du vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
c'est en tout cas ce qui était annoncé
dans l'une il monta en février 2014
moi je voudrais savoir comment
comment ce nouveau quartier
autour du autour du vélodrome à pouvoir
fonctionner dans la ville dans la ville
avec toutes ses ressources et
universitaires dans le centre de saint
quentin on a la chance d'avoir
l'université qui s'est en plus qui a
pris de l'ampleur avec l'ufr des
sciences de la santé
donc quel est le lien physique quel est
le lien fonctionnel entre ce futur
nouveau quartier
et puis le la ville et puis petite
question annexe comment ce quartier sera
animée je pense à des commerces je pense
à des à des cafés puisque ce sera
surtout destiné à des jeunes des jeunes
travailleurs des jeunes des étudiants
des jeunes chercheurs qui seront en
recherche de d'animation de café alors
qu'elle est qu'elle est l'animation qui
est prévu aussi dans ceux dans ce
quartier le développement du vélodrome
c'était important là ça dépasse montigny
c'est complètement sur l'agglomération
de saint girons tard oui à tout un
nouveau quartier à imaginer inventer
quels sont les projets alors d'une part
ce quartier se développe bien sûr c'est
de la responsabilité de la communauté
d'agglo mais avec l'accord complet et la
participation depuis le début de la
ville de montigny et du maire de
montigny
là ça simplifie les choses aujourd'hui
ça m'énerve que sauf que tout a été
lancée au moment où je n'étais pas
encore président donc ce quartier ce
sont des logements spécifiques
c'est ce qu'on appelle agents
spécifiques cyrus est uniquement pour
les étudiants les jeunes travailleurs il
est léger chercheurs dont ce soit
quartier bien sûr il ya aussi des
commerces y aura de l'activité il n'y a
aucun souci ce quartier va bien vivre
d'ailleurs pour donner le meilleur
exemple
nous sommes en train de terminer les
travaux de réaménagement de l'avenue du
pas du lac il faudra bien le lien entre
le quartier et le centre ville
savait il en est à cinq cents mètres
voilà donc ce sera un quartier qui sera
complètement intégrée et au niveau
animation je pense que aussi toute
l'animation autour du
du vélodrome sera aussi importante sans
oublier aussi que nous sommes à l'entrée
de la base de loisirs qui est aussi un
lieu d'animation de loisirs de balades
et de différentes activités dont il ya
aucun souci tout ceci a été bien pensé
tout ceci a bien été étudiés et
d'ailleurs je rappellerai aussi qu' il
ya un immeuble de bureaux va aussi venir
là donc c'est un quartier qui va vivre
et d'ailleurs qui fait le lien qui fait
le lien avec ce qui existait déjà
auparavant et tout ça était budgété
aussi parce que les finances c'est le
nerf de la guerre on parlait tout à
l'heure des soutiens de l'état ne serait
ce qu'à la police mais globalement les
dotations de l'état sont en diminution
pour toutes les collectivités
aujourd'hui à saint quentin en yvelines
a les moyens montigny a les moyens de se
développer
mais bon tu n'y as les besoins de ce
fait lober puisque c'est une opération
privée ce ne sont pas des logements
publics ce sont des logements privés et
les commerces seront bien sûr privé il
n'y a pas de commerce mais avec un
regard tout de même de l'année avec un
regard sur tout ce qui aménage mans sur
l'architecturé est finalement sur l'
équilibre qui peut y avoir le maire que
je suive souhaite aussi que les
personnes qui seront là puis ce bien
vivre sur les finances justement
aujourd'hui avec cet état qui se
désengage ça vous inquiète et bien sûr
je suis inquiet je suis inquiet en tant
que maire je suis inquiet en tant que
président parce que
aujourd'hui nous n'avons avons des
moyens de plus en plus limités dont
seulement il ya le désengagement de
l'état bleus savaient bien borloo voyez
c'était en tout les collectivités ça
devient une option peu difficile mais
vous avez aussi des systèmes de
péréquation qui viennent aussi puiser
dans vos caisses pour alimenter d'autres
d'autres villes la solidarité c'est bien
quand une ville est structurellement
pauvres ça me dérangeait pas de pouvoir
rêver mais il ya différence entre une
ville riche une ville est bien gérée est
une ville pauvre une vie le mal géré
donc là dessus je crois qu'il faudrait
qu'on né peut plus de discernement dans
l'aide dans les aides que nous pouvons
avoir aujourd'hui les finances de la
ville de montigny ce sont saines nous
avons même un petit peu d'avancé qui
nous ce qui va nous permettre de
réaliser les équipements que nous avons
prévus dans le cadre du mandat qui vient
de débuter et dont les promesses faites
seront tenus la solidarité qui va
s'appliquer à une échelle peut être
encore plus grande à l'avenir puisqu'on
parle d'une intercommunalité en tout cas
le préfet de région souhaite huit cent
mille habitants ont relierait à saint
quentin en yvelines avec le versailles
l'agglomération de versailles une partie
de l'essonne aussi c'est faisable
c'est une bonne idée vous savez très
bien que je suis contre depuis le début
c'est tous les élus pratiquement son
contraire tous les élus quels que soient
leurs tendances politiques sont contre
ce périmètre qui est qui et véritable
monstre sur l'argent par izia de huit
cent mille habitants
c'est la plus grande intercommunalité de
france après les métropoles
donc c'est quand même il faut voir c'est
le niveau pour vous donner une idée du
périmètre entre le nord et le sud entre
l'est et l'ouest c'est la distance entre
roissy et orly
de dimensions de ce territoire du
territoire impossible à gérer
57 communes comment voulez vous arrivez
à une gouvernance partagée avec 57
communes
comment vous révoltez vous arrivez à une
organisation qui va comprendre des
internats lite est très intégrée au
niveau intercommunal et d'autres pas du
tout 50 mg bid le niveau d'intégration
de 50% des très grands parcs de 15%
la cape de 16% vous voyez bien que ces
compteurs impossible on va mettre des
années avant de pouvoir
avancer alors qu'aujourd'hui tout ce
qu'il nous faut c'est qu'on nous laisse
travailler grande masse grandir toute
façon le périmètre de saint-quentin doit
évoluer puisque aujourd'hui nous sommes
à 50 eu mille habitants et la loi nous
impose d'être à plus de deux cent mille
habitants vous avez déjà ce projet avec
mord pas la clé sous bois nous avons le
projet qui existe qui ne t'a pas d'hier
il n'adopte pas depuis la nouvelle loi
depuis déjà quelques années nous
souhaitons intégrer dans le territoire
des communes qui pour une moitié y était
déjà 10 points de batimat en création
d'un nouvel exactement et donc on
souhaite nous travailler sur un
véritable bassin de vie sur un périmètre
cohérent nous à permettre de vraiment
faire avancer les choses par contre on
est tout à fait pour favorable au
développement de paris saclay et donc
rien ne nous empêche de nous le faisons
déjà de travailler avec les autres
intercommunalités avec la caps avec
versailles grand parc avec rhdp sonne on
siègent ensemble ou qu'on sait
dministration de le pps les très
nombreux public de paris saclay on a
déjà une aop sur le transport dont vous
voyez bien que on a déjà commencé depuis
longtemps de travailler
on n'a pas besoin est que l'état nous
disent ce qu'on doit faire
vous avez été reconduit jusqu'en 2020 ce
sera a priori la date des prochaines
élections municipales
et puis ça changera aussi pour
l'agglomération de saint quentin très
rapidement si un engagement que vous
pouvez prendre aujourd'hui devant les
électeurs que vous vous engagez à
réaliser sur votre mandat à l'elysée
beck deux ans en 2020 d'accord non mais
tout simplement que je reste le même
voilà que je reste l'élu que tout le
monde connaît et que je ne change pas
c'est assez facile c'est pas trop
difficile pour vous hébert rodez des
examens mais la tentation de changer
examinant point nommé et xavier bien
autour de vous et vous verrez que des
élus qui restent stables pendant de
nombreuses années
c'est exceptionnel merci à michel
laugier et maire de montigny le
bretonneux président de la communauté
d'agglomération de saint-quentin café
politique qui revient le 5 octobre
invité cette fois-ci françois de ligne
et le maire de guyancourt maire
socialiste également conseiller général
à